Quizás hayas escuchado
que nos estamos quedando sin agua.
Esto puede sonar extraño porque,
si vives en un lugar donde
el agua fluye libremente
en cualquier momento desde la ducha,
seguro que esto no parece gran cosa.
Simplemente está ahí, ¿no?
Incorrecto.
Lo único obvio sobre el agua dulce
es cuánto la necesitamos.
Porque es esencial para la vida,
Debemos pensarlo cuidadosamente.
Ahora, en este mismo momento,
algunas personas,
en particular mujeres y niñas,
caminan horas y kilómetros diariamente
para obtener agua dulce,
y aún así, puede que no sea limpia.
Cada 15 segundos un niño muere
por el agua contaminada.
Esto es trágico.
Las razones más apremiantes
para pensar sobre el agua dulce,
por lo tanto, tienen que ver
con lo que podríamos llamar
el bien común global.
En esto no pensamos normalmente,
pero significa reconocer
la importancia del agua dulce
para el florecimiento de la vida humana
y no humana en la Tierra
ahora y en el futuro.
¿Cómo pensamos en algo
como locales ante nuestras duchas
y como globales ante el agua dulce?
¿Existe una conexión entre ambas cosas?
Muchas personas asumen que la escasez
del agua dulce
es debida al despilfarro individual:
dejar correr el agua mientras uno
se cepilla los dientes, por ejemplo,
o ducharse largo rato.
La mayoría de nosotros
asume, por lo tanto,
que la escasez de agua
puede solucionarse
mejorando nuestros hábitos personales:
duchándonos en menos tiempo
o cerrando el agua
mientras nos cepillamos los dientes.
Sin embargo, la escasez de agua
no comienza ni termina en la ducha.
Globalmente, el uso doméstico del agua dulce
representa sólo el 8 % del consumo,
el 8 %
Compara eso con el 70 %
que va a la agricultura
y el 22 % que se destina
a usos industriales.
Ahora, espera, ¡no te desconectes!
Los hábitos individuales siguen siendo
parte del rompecabezas.
Debemos seguir ahorrando agua en la vida diaria,
cerremos el agua al cepillarnos los dientes.
Pero aún así, es cierto.
Ducharnos menos rato no resuelve
los problemas globales,
que son muy grave.
Sería mucho más sencillo y más fácil
si las acciones individuales meritorias
pudieran hacer magia.
Sólo estarías ahí allí
durante 30 segundos menos,
y harías esta tarea
molesta para salvar el para el día.
Bueno, eso no es el caso.
Patrones agrícolas e industriales
del uso del agua
necesita revisarse seriamente.
¿Cómo valoran nuestras sociedades el agua?
¿Distribuyéndola?
¿Subvencionando su uso en la agricultura?
¿Incentivando su consumo o contaminación?
Estas son todas las preguntas
que se derivan
de cómo pensamos sobre valor del agua dulce.
¿Es un bien económico?
¿Un derecho humano?
¿Un bien público?
Ganadores del Premio Nobel,
activistas global de justicia del agua,
instituciones transnacionales como la ONU,
e incluso la iglesia católica
están trabajando en el tema.
Pero, es difícil, también,
porque el negocio del agua
llegó a ser muy rentable en el siglo XX.
Y el beneficio no es lo mismo que el bien común.
Necesitamos averiguar
cómo valorar el agua como un bien público,
algo que es vital para la vida humana y no humana,
ahora y en el futuro.
Ahora es una tarea colectiva, virtuosa
va mucho más allá de la ducha.